[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic has taken a
massive psychological toll on people
worldwide from recovering from serious
infections to experiencing deaths in
one's family or circle of friends
or even job loss in isolation people are
coping at least in part in very
different ways
on today's program we'll see how
volunteers in places like india are
looking after coronavirus patients
but in other parts of the world people
are ignoring the virus and the risk of
infection
but first to hong kong where those
entering the country first have to
quarantine
our reporter hang shen experienced it
first hand but didn't let it bring her
down
[Music]
curved 19 not only causes an illness
with physical symptoms but it can also
impact your mental health throughout the
pandemic coronavirus restrictions put
many people in a form of isolation that
is unprecedented in the modern world i
also experienced it in quite an extreme
way during a 14-day quarantine in hong
kong the city is well known for its
harsh coronavirus restrictions i was
confined in a hotel room not allowed to
see anyone and i'd like to share with
you how the confinement turned out for
me
this is the hotel room where i stayed
for two weeks i have to say that i was
among the lucky ones
my room was relatively comfortable i
could open the window a little bit even
though this is forbidden in a lot of
quarantine hotels
and from the window i could observe how
people were living their lives
i got my meals three times a day
but that didn't mean i got to see anyone
in person
when i arrived it didn't take me long to
discover this little notebook i quite
like this sentence on a cover if you
don't like something change it if you
can't change it change your attitude
out of curiosity i checked out the term
location online it's a program organized
by the center for suicide research and
prevention at the university of hong
kong
well i had nothing to do so i decided to
call them up
what happens when people are isolated
for too long
our university did a number of surveys
throughout the pandemic a lot of times
the interviewees said they felt very
lonely
their level of anxiety and depression
also increased
this isn't really the case
so in our booklet we introduced some
little exercises to make people feel
that they have the power to decide on
something again
we also asked people to clean their
rooms
or dress up even if they're not going
anywhere
all of these things can bring back the
sense of control
little practices like this
brewing and savoring a cup of tea to
train our mindfulness
and they also told me to exercise every
day it felt good
another tip from the team was to stay
connected with others i was really glad
to have many friends visiting me
regularly
additionally i set different personal
goals like practicing guitar and
learning russian a few times a week
[Music]
i was isolated but did not feel lonely
[Music]
another week passed by quickly
soon i found myself packing my luggage
once again in about 10 minutes i will
leave this room after 14 days of
quarantine i'm super excited but i'm
also a little bit scared to step out of
this room i've been captivated for too
long
anyway i'll see you later bye
[Music]
the first welcoming hug ever since i
arrived here
after my friend picked me up we took a
taxi back home
hello i'm almost there
first time seeing my parents again in
two and a half years
unfortunately hong kong is experiencing
its worst coronavirus wave ever despite
its tough rules the government is
responding with even tougher measures to
cut the spread of the virus so for me
it's like moving from one quarantine to
another but i think my experience in the
past two weeks has made me mentally a
little stronger it is a difficult time
but i'm sure everything will turn out
fine and if you are in isolation right
now please hang on because one day it
will be over
while some are learning to cope with
quarantine and isolation others are
still trying to ignore the coronavirus
two years into the pandemic
this is not only prevalent in european
countries including germany but also on
other continents in brazil the
population's willingness to wear a mask
or to get vaccinated has declined
significantly
[Music]
in the past year corolla barcelos marcel
has administered more than 15 000 doses
she is convinced that the vaccine is the
only way to control the pandemic
although the unvaccinated are a minority
in brazil they represent 88 of current
hospitalizations in the country
working on the front line she has
witnessed the skepticism of many
a lot of people are coming to get
vaccinated for the first time now while
some are even taking the fourth dose
many are only coming now because they
have an uncle or a sister or someone
close to them who got the virus and
developed a complication or is intubated
and that has made them realize the
importance of the vaccine
last month brazil recorded the highest
number of new infections since the
outbreak of the pandemic even surpassing
the deadly peaks of the first and second
waves
almost 100 percent of those cases were
caused by the omicron strain
but despite the difficult situation
barely anyone still wears a mask or
maintains social distancing after two
years with the virus brazilians are
tired of the restrictions but relaxing
those restrictions could lead to an
explosion of infections
researcher vinicius oliveira from fio
cruz one of the most respected
scientific institutions of brazil
refuses to meet us in person to avoid
the risk of transmission
he anticipates a challenging situation
in the coming weeks
we'll see a large increase in the number
of infections even much larger than the
testing capacity
so we'll need to look at this data very
carefully
we'll see an increase in
hospitalizations and deaths which will
continue to rise for another month or
two
we'll maintain a high level of
hospitalizations compared with what we
had in november and january
carola finishes her shift at this health
center and goes to another one where she
also works
she knows that the unvaccinated under
threat from the contagious omicron
variant could push the country's
healthcare system to the limit
even as many countries in the world have
been easing their coronavirus
extrictions the pandemic is still
omnipresent children in particular have
suffered a great deal over the past two
years
they've often not understood what's
happening around them
[Music]
that makes it all the more important for
adults to take the time to explain it to
them
[Music]
children pick up far more than adults
realize
covet measures affect them directly they
see images of the war in ukraine in
addition to news about animals going
extinct and the worsening climate crisis
sometimes they simply feel the tension
fear or anger of the adults around them
that is why it is important that we talk
to kids about the crises
but how do i do it right
hold on i have a few tips for you and
you guys
take children's feelings seriously a
crying child needs comfort believe it or
not you don't have to be afraid isn't
the best way to respond to a child's
fear
it diminishes the feeling making the
child think their concern is
inappropriate and maybe even forbidden
a better response i understand you it
scares me too
uh wait you want me to admit that i'm
scared too
won't that scare my child even more
nope
don't be afraid of your own fear
children benefit when adults are
authentic in order to have a
conversation about feelings adults
should be aware of their own emotions
and capable of expressing them
what we shouldn't do however is
overwhelm the little ones with our
emotions they shouldn't feel like they
have to soothe and comfort us
okay i got that but what do i say now
let the child guide you
you can use the child's questions to
determine the level and complexity of
the conversation
you shouldn't lecture just guide based
on what the child wants to know what if
my child asks what we can do to help is
it a good idea to participate in
protests with children
i'm glad you're asking that brings me to
my last point
children expect adults and especially
their parents to protect them
that means that being informed and
having a fact-based conversation
sometimes isn't enough
we can also try to make positive change
with our children
by participating in a demonstration for
example or collecting donations
do you know what self-efficacy is
um the feeling of managing a difficult
situation on your own
exactly
we can't solve any of the major crises
as individuals but within our means we
can work to make change thereby
strengthening our self-efficacy and
reducing feelings of helplessness
this applies to children but also to
adults
doing something for yourself is a way to
cope with the crisis
it's helped lots of people during the
pandemic
in india there are also volunteers who
support affected families with groceries
medicine and money
for some of them it's a part of their
belief system
that's the case for these volunteers at
an ngo near new delhi
there have now been more than 1.8
million infections in the region
these men are volunteering their time to
practice a central tenet of sikhism
service to the community
that includes distributing free food
also known as langar
gurpreet singh rumi the head of this
sikh temple
says that these meals will go out to the
homes of coronavirus patients
there is no discrimination here members
of every community sit together to eat
longer we're even packing lunger here to
send to the homes of people who aren't
well this is what guru nanak taught us
last year this commitment to service
made the difference between life and
death for thousands of people
india's second wave of coronavirus cases
driven by the delta variant overwhelmed
hospitals
and exhausted oxygen supplies
we visited the camp set up by khalsa
help international to distribute free
oxygen
we need 100 oxygen cylinders every
second
we have eight trucks scoring supplies
all over india right now
in six weeks the camp helped over 14 000
people
deepa was one of the volunteers at the
medical center
her family didn't want her to work
during the delta wave given the risks at
the oxygen camp
but then khalsa helped saved her uncle
my uncle searched everywhere in the
state and he couldn't find medical
oxygen he finally got help here
now my family completely supports my
decision to work here i feel proud of
being part of this
for those whose lives were saved during
this difficult time
rumi is a hero
but he says serving the community is
integral to his faith
the temple offers free medical treatment
and checkups
as well as coronavirus vaccinations and
tests
they're also providing support to
families in financial difficulty due to
the pandemic
families
we've adopted 62 families who have lost
their bread winners to the coronavirus
they pay their children school fees
we send them food rations and groceries
we will bear their costs until one of
them can start earning
things are calm right now
but rumi says his team is already
speaking to medical experts to find out
how to prepare for the next wave
his own bouts with the coronavirus don't
scare him he says
he's just trying to live up to his duty
to help
our science correspondent derek williams
has also wanted to help out since the
beginning of the pandemic
he answers your questions and hopefully
removes a little bit of your uncertainty
in the process
this time susan m wants to know
what does research say about repeated
infections
this is one of those million dollar
topics that we're still learning about
it's been clear from the beginning of
the pandemic
that sars kobe 2 might potentially
reinfect people regularly over time
after all
there are other coronaviruses
the four which generally cause cold like
symptoms
that can infect us multiple times
throughout our lives now
two years in
it's clear that sars kobe 2 might share
that ability
we know that immunity to it wanes over
time that's why
covet 19 vaccine booster shots are are
now recommended
but what does the potential for
re-infection
really mean well let's look at what the
data says so far since we know that
re-infections are possible a big
question is
how often they could reoccur
health authorities largely agree that an
otherwise healthy individual who
recovers from covet 19 is at low risk of
getting it again
for at least a few months but that's not
zero risk
it's basically impossible to quantify
your own individual risk because
each person is going to have a different
immunological experience with the
disease
some infected people will get bad cases
and others won't even notice they were
infected
and and those experiences have an
influence on your immune response
to subsequent exposures um one place the
evidence
is really pretty solid though is that
what's called
hybrid immunity which is a combination
of vaccination
and infection
that it provides
more robust protection than infection
alone does so
experts say that even if you had the
disease
it's still a good idea to go ahead and
get vaccinated anyway but it's also
important to note that the omicron
variant has changed the playing field
because
it's more immune evasive than earlier
variants were that means
that it's better at infecting people
with existing immunity whether they've
acquired it from from vaccination
or from prior infection um that ability
the experts say
is a big factor in the massive spikes in
numbers of infections that we've seen
in many countries in the last few months
but what does that mean when it comes to
disease severity i mean if you get covet
19 again will it be less severe
[Music]
there the news from studies is
cautiously positive one conducted in the
middle east involving over 1300
confirmed re-infections for instance
said that they were 90 percent less
likely to hospitalize or to kill people
the second time around so
when reinfection does happen
most experts are saying they would
expect the course of the disease to in
general
be milder
some people have used art to process
what they've experienced during the
pandemic
including a young photographer from
bangladesh who now lives in berlin
she created a series of photos that have
been featured in an exhibit
they're dedicated to the people in her
homeland and their suffering
[Music]
the way people died all alone
it was really super sad things to see
so i know lots of people they lost their
parents relatives and
they couldn't manage to see them for the
last time as well
salma abedin pretty aims to show the
effects of the coronavirus pandemic in
her home country bangladesh with her
photo series torn
it's also a way for the 37 year old
artist who now lives in berlin to come
to terms with her own distressing
encounters with the virus
my father-in-law died that time and also
i got
bad copied i had like permanent damage
on my right eyes and i got the
spondylysis disease through the kovet
and
you can imagine
like so many things and we didn't have
that much that much time to
like
think about
laws and pain we are just
having
so many things one after another then
when my father-in-law died and then
after eight months later my
mother-in-law also died
and i got this
long-time kobe so we
i feel that i am in a battlefield and
fighting all the time with the situation
i had actually no plan to work on kobe
so when the kobe
came to bangladesh you know everybody
was super scared we don't know how to
react we don't know nothing
so in the meantime there was
lots of news came
to the newspaper and social media
which
surprised me a lot shocked me a lot and
i started collecting those news
personal experiences were not being
featured in bangladesh strictly
regulated media
as part of a scholarship pretty began to
focus on them and to show people's
stories in her pop-up photo studio in
dhaka
i wanted to make
something
maybe
more focused on
trauma or more focus on
pain
individual individually you know in
newspaper and document daily maybe so
many cases is coming one after another
but i wanted to make it focus on
individual incident
the plight of working-class people is at
the center of british torn series
the lockdown cast them into an
existential crisis from one day to the
next
[Music]
when the
lockdown started
then
we found that
this situation very much extreme for the
working class people we knew that that
is we knew that
these things exist
visible but we are very ignorant
so
that time i first experienced that
someone is
coming in front my road and asking for
rice
and working class people they don't know
like they work on daily basis and they
get payment and they live their life
like this they don't have any savings
one of mother
she just
like sold her hair
to get some rice
they
like this kind of people they suffered a
lot
and
they are starting telling that it's
better to die with corona rather than
hunger
when bangladesh's garment factories
reopened with a coronavirus still
prevalent workers were suddenly faced
with a new kind of problem
when they
stay in the city they have to rent a
place you know and
small place
lots of people staying together because
they cannot afford to be alone in the
city and afford one room so in our one
room during the kobe time also when
everybody is talking about isolation if
you go to the slum how could we manage
the isolation
pretty blames bangladesh's society as
well as the government's poor covert
policies for people's needless suffering
during the pandemic i
really need one of the policemen he
did suicide
when he got copied he just fell off from
the roof
he jumped i should not tell pilaf he
just jumped from the roof
he was so scared also
and if you
if you don't have like clear direction
on anything people get more confused and
more depressed
they don't know what to do with this
thing they're more scared and
more incident will happen
yeah
torn has already been on show in berlin
where the photos were also shortlisted
for a talent award
the jury citing their impressive and
contemporary take on this subject
[Music]
we've all learned many new ways to deal
with the coronavirus pandemic whether
alone together or providing help for
others
hopefully we've been able to provide you
with a little food for thought
the virus and its mutations will be with
us for a while making innovative
approaches that allow us to better cope
with the situation all the more
important
we'll explore some of them in our next
show
until then so long and stay healthy
[Music]
you